speaking of a furious basement dwelling
trump
this is fascinating and hilarious donald
trump has been completely embarrassed by
uh world leaders including the german
chancellor angela merkel
who turned down trump's invitation to
come to the u.s for the g7 summit at the
white house so understand the back story
for a few weeks now the white house has
continued to talk about we want to do
the g7 we we might do it at camp david
we might do it at the white house
uh coronavirus no i think we're going to
be able to do it it's going to be really
really great and reporters smartly were
asking
should you be doing this given the
pandemic but also which world leaders
have accepted your invitation
so far and they didn't say but they just
kept insisting
trump did and kaylee mcinanni world
leaders are reacting very favorably
we're going to have news about this soon
yada yada hopefully it'll happen at the
end of june everything's going to be
fine
we suspected this was bs most world
leaders
clearly from what they say understand
this is not the time to be traveling all
over the world possibly spreading
coronavirus
to come and give trump his photo op at
the white house or camp david
and one of the first to turn down the
invitation
over the weekend was german chancellor
angela merkel who essentially said no
thanks she said
i'm not going it's too early to reopen
we shouldn't be having large gatherings
the virus is very much
circulating and trump reportedly
furious at angela merkel and then trump
does this thing that
you know it's not surprising but it's so
pathetic
trump decides to pretend it was really
his decision not to do the g7
and that the countries that are
currently in it aren't really the right
ones
calls it an outdated group and according
to
press pool reports donald trump said i'm
postponing it
because i don't feel as a g7 it probably
represents what's going on in the world
it's a very outdated group trump
mentioning that he wants to add
russia and some other countries to the
group so
this is an obvious lie trump is
postponing it because
nobody's coming they've turned down the
invitation at least angela merkel has
world leaders said no and now trump is
pretending he didn't want it
to happen with this group anyway and the
entire you know adding russia thing and
the group being outdated this is how
trump
um attacks people that
don't want to say yes to him quite
simply it's just
everything is a childish temper tantrum
now just
imagine what trump will do if he loses
in november
it will be like nothing we have seen
before from any president
one other sort of interesting thing
about the whole g7 fiasco
this is why diplomats exist in a normal
administration
you don't have trump for a month saying
we're going to push for g7 and
the leaders are reacting very positively
very strong positive reactions
in a normal situation diplomats figure
all of this out
you don't put trump out there on a limb
saying we're doing the g7 and we're
doing it here even though they're not
actually
yet scheduled to do it then you end up
with world leaders saying no thanks and
trump tries to save face by saying well
i want
better countries in it anyway in a
normal administration diplomats handle
this
there will be one statement about it and
it is either we have decided to postpone
the g7 due to coronavirus spheres
or we are confirmed having the g7
on such and such date you avoid all of
these embarrassing fiascos in the first
place
this is all self-harm done by donald
trump
and the degree to which he is being
shunned by world leaders
is really representative of just a slide
down the totem pole so to speak for the
u.s
presidency globally it's embarrassing to
americans
it needs to change and just imagine
this is what trump is doing over angela
merkel saying no thanks
just imagine what he will do if he is
indeed defeated
in november privacy.com is one of our
sponsors and they're giving you five
dollars just for using their free
service at
privacy.com pacman privacy is a service
i've been using for a while now
i love it it saves me a bunch of
headaches it's completely free
and it's very quick to set up and here's
how it works when you pay for something
online or over the phone
instead of exposing your real credit
card number
privacy lets you generate virtual card
numbers
the payments are withdrawn from your
checking account but your real card
number
stays completely private and you do it
all with one click you can autofill the
card number in your web browser
on the phone you can create 12 virtual
cards a month you can set
spending limits freeze them delete them
whenever you want
i especially love it for free trials
where you need to give a credit card
number
because i can destroy the virtual card
number as soon as i give it to the
company and i know i won't be charged in
the future
if you're ordering food over the phone
why do i need to give a restaurant my
real card number
if i don't have to companies don't have
to know who you are
your real credit card number is
protected from the data breaches that
happen unfortunately more often than we
would like and it's completely free
they do have a paid version with
different tiers where you can create
more virtual credit card numbers per
month cash back rewards extra security
features
but go ahead and sign up for the free
service it's a no-brainer companies
can't charge you unexpectedly
you're protected from identity theft it
costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you five dollars
to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy.com
slash pacman